whoa before we get started I want to go
over the four sponsors for this episode
who make all this possible
they're fantastic so go show them some
love the first is the best URL in the
industry crypto comm they're crypto
platform with one goal driving mass
adoption that's why we're all here right
to get every human on earth a digital
wallet and to get them using digital
currencies crypto comms helping people
do that through buying earning lending
and a new card payment everything you
could want is at crypto calm they've
been longtime supporters of
off-the-chain and recently announced a
new exchange so go help them out
download their app from the App Store or
visit crypto comm and tell them pom sent
you there's nothing better in the world
than a company helping to drive global
adoption of this new technology another
part of global adoption is making sure
that we secure the various block chains
with computing power coin line has built
the best consumer experience in mining
hands-down no competition if you want to
help secure the blockchain and get
started in mining you can go to coin
mine comm slash pump or direct cone mine
it'll arrive at your door and you simply
take out of the box plug it in and
connect to your Wi-Fi you'll be mining
your favorite crypto in five minutes or
less it is honestly magical I have one
running right now here in the office and
it's super quiet
it's got no heat and every person that
comes in the office asks what is that
every single person asks it's a coin
mine the best part to me is that the
coin mine comes with a mobile app that's
super slick and the company continues to
push over-the-air updates to the device
that add functionality add tokens that
can be mine or increase the efficiency
of the device similar to how Tesla does
car software updates over-the-air Cohen
mines sending these passively to
thousands of coin mines around the world
on a periodic basis pretty damn cool
when far booed and the team pitched me
on the idea of an Xbox or Playstation
like box that could mine cryptocurrency
in your home I was immediately sold I
invested in the business have a device
personally and keep telling people to go
to coin mine comm slash pump so they can
save a lot of time if they want to get
started mining today in coin mine has a
partnership with our third sponsor for
this episode block-by-block flies one of
my favorite companies in crypto because
they allow users to deposit their assets
in a deposit account and immediately
start earning interest think about it if
you keep your digital assets on an
exchange or in cold storage your
benefiting from any yield on the asset
with block Phi they allow you to deposit
crypto and then get paid interest on a
monthly basis in crypto deposit Bitcoin
and want to get your interest payment in
eath you can do it
deposit bitcoin and want to get your
interest payment in bitcoin you can do
it the rates of block fire are currently
some of the best in the industry
you can earn 6% interest on Bitcoin and
you can earn up to eight point six
percent 8py on G USD deposits I'm an
investor in the company and think block
five building really important and
compelling infrastructure so go check
them out at block five comm slash pop
again that's block five comm slash pop
and that brings us to the last
advertiser of the episode eToro these
guys have absolutely crushed it over the
years their founder yoni was one of the
original Bitcoin OGIS that has been
ahead of almost every trend in crypto he
built eToro to help people buy sell and
trade cryptocurrencies but he added a
few twists social trading copy trading
and virtual trading accounts social
trading is a feature where every asset
available on the platform has its own
separate social feed where people talk
about the asset share trading ideas and
analysis and even include various charts
or graphs virtual trading accounts is
targeted at beginners if you're just
starting out and want to try trading
with play money eToro will give you a
virtual account with $100,000 in it to
test learn and get comfortable and so
then that brings us to copy trading
which is by far the coolest feature this
allows you as a user to select any other
users portfolio to copy if you see
someone on the platform you like you can
set your account to mimic their trades
they buy Bitcoin with 5% of their
portfolio your portfolio buys 5% Bitcoin
they sell 50% of their ether position
your portfolio does the same thing
automatically copy trading is awesome so
go join the ten plus million other
traders on eToro
and start trading all the most popular
cryptocurrencies today they're one of
the largest companies in the space and
you can get started by going to e Toro
comm again that is otário comm where the
entire team is ready to get you started
in just a few clicks and don't forget go
subscribe to the off-the-chain daily
newsletter you can go to off-the-chain
sub stack comm i write a letter of news
analysis and a pain every morning that
goes out to more than 40,000 investors
see you there
what's up everyone this is Anthony pop
Leon Oh most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the change
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off
alright guys bang bang I'm sitting here
with a special guest for the 200th
episode of off the chain we're gonna do
something a little different
I shot out a tweet and said use the
hashtag asked pomp to send in your
questions and I'm gonna answer as many
of them as I can during the episode in
order to help me go through the
questions I've brought in the ever
lovely Polina Mironova
to to help read them out so she's gonna
suffer through this with us yep I'm
excited to make my debut Jesus all right
let's start with the first question
okay this one comes from a crypto Nero
how many years did you ignore this face
before being convinced you saying you
started with eath mining was surprising
yeah actually what I met you you were
not into Bitcoin yeah so I think that I
couldn't say that I ignored the industry
it was more of AI just was ignorant too
and I didn't I didn't know it I didn't
know about it I think I'd heard the word
Bitcoin two or three times when I was
working at a facebook 2014/2015 but
there was a gentleman JP Burke who
really sat me down and I was like hey
you should pay attention to this but it
was all around mining and so I had a
background in data centers and
understood how those worked and so when
I saw Bitcoin and ethereal mining it was
a no-brainer right away but yes we
started with with eath mining with GPUs
what's the next one at jtv 95 wants to
know the justice system hasn't been
built for the internet lots of online
crimes don't even get looked into do you
think there will be a justice system
built for the internet if so how do you
think it could work
yeah it's great question I think that
there's two ways to think about
quote-unquote justice some of it is
preventive
some of it is reactionary and so if you
think about the justice system that we
have you know in the analog world or the
non internet world a lot of its
reactionary so basically what ends up
happening is you do whatever you want
and when even though you know you're
about to do something that's wrong you
can still do it and then once you've
done that the law enforcement takes a
lot of time energy and resources to to
build a case and going force on you I
think what we're starting to see in the
Internet age especially in financial
services is more of a proactive approach
to justice or law enforcement where
basically the software has the rules
coded into it and it prevents you from
being able to do things again especially
in financial services where there's
heavy regulation I think that that is
you know a trend that that's becoming
more popular now with that said there's
a flip side to it which is people should
still have kind of free choice and
freedom individual liberties so if all
of a sudden we start to prevent people
from doing things because we just don't
like their ideas I think that's a
slippery slope and so there's a balance
to strike there but but but I do think
that there's a difference between kind
of proactive and reactionary approaches
and the internet definitely is
empowering people to take more proactive
approaches than than before this was
from Hunter Horsley man what is part of
modern life that you think in 30 years
will look back on and say wow I can't
believe we did that yes great question
there's by two pieces one I do believe
that we're gonna look back and be like
humans used to be really stupid because
they had to count on themselves and what
I mean by that is I think we're probably
you know I don't know somewhere between
let's call it 15 and 50 years away from
true embeddable technology so you can
imagine the ability now for a chip to be
embedded in your brain now you have all
of the access
of Google and the internet and all that
information right at your your
fingertips or kind of as part of the
computational power in your brain you
can imagine that once we get to that
point where every human has that
capability I think we'll look back a bit
wow I can't believe that they actually
used their real brains without
augmentation and so I think that's
something to pay attention to a second
trend that is somewhat more
controversial is the idea that the meat
that we eat today is natural I think
that you see things with like impossible
foods beyond meat etc it would not
surprise me at all if there's an ethical
argument that ends up getting made
around the the inhumane treatment of
animals and therefore the lab-grown meat
becomes more popular and eventually
becomes kind of dominant now there's a
lot of questions around how is that
scientifically kind of healthy and what
those impacts are but but I definitely
think that's something to pay attention
to and I'm sure that there's other
things you know self-driving cars I
can't believe those people actually
drove around you know if you think of
that type of technology it's likely that
the self-driving cars are yes gonna
replace some jobs but more so they're
going to unlock a lot of time for
creation and creativity and production
from humans and actually how much time
people spend in cars not doing something
other than driving and so I think that's
again that's something that people will
just look back and say well I can't
believe Asus sit in a car and so that'll
be something to pay attention to this is
a good one from elgible what is your
next goal be clear be as clear as
possible my next goal that's a really
good question I think I've got a whole
bunch of different goals most of my
goals end up being pretty long-term
stuff you know for me one that's easy I
think for this audience to kind of wrap
their head around is in 2017 I put a
really big focus on figuring out Twitter
and growing that audience in 2018 I put
a pretty big focus on
kind of systematizing and in figuring
out how to grow the off-the-chain
newsletter in 2019 i spent a lot of time
kind of systematizing and learning how
to grow the podcast and so for 2020 I
think that one of the the big goals for
me is to figure out YouTube and what
that really looks like is can I go from
the you know six seven thousand
subscribers that we have today to a
hundred thousand subscribers by the end
of 2020 I think would would kind of show
that we've gotten the mastery of that
platform how the algorithms work the
type of content people want kind of
distribution but then also the systems
in place on the content creation side
and so if you think about it from why is
that important you know now we basically
have four platforms where if there's any
sort of algorithm changes on the YouTube
or a Twitter or any other platform you
kind of have multiple channels some
direct where you own the relationship
with the end user and then some that are
more kind of mass distribution like the
Twitter's and YouTube's but that's
definitely a goal that I think is a
short-term based and pretty measurable
awesome this is from at Gregg in 1976 13
Wow when you pitch family offices
blockchain and Bitcoin what are their
reasons for saying no and how has this
changed over the years yep so there's
every I think conversation is different
the largest conversations are sort of
larger family offices those
conversations what I've taken away from
it it's like the easy answer is we're
gonna do nothing so when you're
presented with a new idea it takes some
forward thinking some courage and it
takes action to follow even if you buy
into you know kind of the pitch that
you're hearing and so it's very easy
simple and kind of that the the default
to do nothing but once you actually
decide okay this is interesting then
you've got to figure out a lot of stuff
around custody how are you going to
acquire it what are the regulations is
there any sort of documentation or
requirements for the structure of the
family office that you need to be
cognizant of etc
so I think if the default is do nothing
we can convince people they'll take
action but then there's another group
but I think the group you're hinting at
here which is the group that here's the
pitch and then decides not to do
something and that group is really doing
it because they don't believe in it or
they don't think it's a good investment
opportunity and usually those come down
to one there's a regulatory uncertainty
in their opinion so they're not
interested - they're worried about
custody or volatility a third thing is
they just start kind of like Fiat
maximalist if they don't believe that
there's any sort of currency that could
you know become popular and kind of take
over and normally what I try to explain
to them is there's a qualitative and a
quantitative argument the qualitative
argument is everything that kind of
bitcoiners and the crypto community
believes around the possibilities of
this asset and and so that's a little
bit harder I think for a lot of folks to
wrap their heads around it they're not
in this every single day but the
quantitative argument is pretty hard to
refute in terms of the non-correlated
assets with an asymmetric upside and the
impact it can have on our portfolio
given the Modern Portfolio theory and so
I think that's really where we try to
focus more it's just using math and data
to show them what an asset like this can
do for their portfolio and obviously
we've been now we've been pretty
fortunate to find some like-minded
individuals there and we'll continue to
do that Jim iam group asks Bitcoin size
digital is cool and all but what happens
when networks go down or blacked out
what's the hedge against local blackouts
yeah so we saw this actually in in
Venezuela their entire grid went down
and there was a couple of things that
people did so the first thing to
remember is if the grid goes down the
legacy banking system goes down but with
Bitcoin basically you don't need the
entire grid to be up you yourself just
need to be able to get access to the
Internet
and so when that happens I think that
you need to be able to one have some
sort of electricity generation so you
can think of just having a generator
you know solar so something like that -
is that you gotta be able to get
internet connection established and and
some people I think in Venezuela were
showing that they could literally get a
via satellite and kind of get out so the
beauty of kind of the grid going down
for something like Bitcoin is that as
long as you yourself can get internet
and electricity then you can connect to
that that network because it's always
running and so you're not dependent on
the entire like National Grid or banking
system to be up and running this is from
at coin Dorado
what were your hobby / interests during
your time in the Army I mean no surprise
working out shooting guns and then
actually read a lot so I for whatever
reason I was young I was just when I was
deployed I was 20 21 years old and
pretty much spent most of my day working
out and then obviously the the weapons
proficiency was important given what we
were doing on a day to day basis so
spent a lot of time on that and then as
I've talked about a ton I specifically
read a lot of books but there was three
specific ones that were quite
foundational to my life my read Rich Dad
Poor Dad by Robert Kiyosaki the richest
man in Babylon and thinking Grow Rich
and those three books I read kind of
back to back to back I was 20 years old
and they really changed the way that I
thought about money and work and wealth
and kind of what I wanted to defend my
life doing and so that was a big focus
along with that kind of physical
activity and the weapons proficiency
this one is from at Walsh SR cm why
wouldn't a deflationary currency be bad
theoretically people would spend almost
solely on necessities and save the rest
to increase their wealth this would
obviously crush economic growth and
therefore is my biggest concern about
BTC
yeah so I think that there's a very
important conversation around
consumption versus savings and we live
in a world that has been driven by
consumption fiat currency the
inflationary aspect of it incentivizes
you to spend money so either to take
your fiat currency and buy goods and
services or to take your fiat currency
and put it into assets real assets
things like real estate stocks so you
know whatever it ends up being and so
the reason why it's important
conversation is obviously Bitcoin has a
very different approach it is a
deflationary structure with a
disinflationary monetary schedule and so
you're actually incentivized to save now
the reason why this is important is if
you go back for thousands of years
things like gold were money and those
have very similar structures to what
bitcoin is today and so I think that
what we have to remember here is that
the Fiat experiment is actually quite
short it's only been around since about
1971 and so we've got you know give or
take 50 years of this experiment and yes
there has been incredible economic
growth but also there's been incredible
economic issues as well and so there's a
strong belief I think among a lot of
people that that inflationary experiment
what we're starting to see here is kind
of the kicking of the can down the road
now first it was interest rate
manipulation right and and movement now
we're starting to see the QE over the
last decade and so yeah that's kind of
come become a constant neccessity
from central bank's to to keep the
economy going but once they don't have
the ability to impact the economy with
interest rates and with QE anymore
because we're addicted to it or kind of
used to it all of a sudden they have to
go to something else and I think this is
where you see things like monitor
monetary Theory mmt come in to etc and
so I think that there's this general
belief that over time there's a bet that
that system or that experiment ends up
not working out in the long run and
something like Bitcoin is really a
return back to
served as money for thousands of years
and so I don't think that people should
be worried about it as much as they
should just have the historical context
of what money has been for a really long
time two questions one from app Matt
we'd a how can i educate my relatives
about bitcoin and then someone at Joey
Clarke V also crypto UGA shoutout go
Dawgs
he said yeah what's your elevator pitch
for why BTC for the average Joe to that
much yeah so I think that the key piece
here there's there's two things one is
there's tons of resources online you
know the things that I've seen people
use that's been quite effective so Murad
and I recorded in a podcast episode this
is going on probably over a year ago now
that that was kind of the bowl case for
Bitcoin I know a lot of people have had
their relatives listen to that and
that's really kind of changed the way
that they thought about it obviously the
Bitcoin standard buy safe teen is a is a
great book that I think a lot of people
kind of enjoy reading and understanding
again the historical context a more
macro components of this and then things
like Jameson law has a great Bitcoin
resource
I think it's lop net slash Bitcoin that
has pretty much you know every talk that
you could imagine every book every
article etc that that would be helpful
in this conversation so I would say
those three resources are pretty strong
in terms of like what's the pitch pitch
is pretty easy I usually tell them look
there's a financial system that you've
grown up in it's an inflationary US
dollar denominated system that's built
on fractional reserve banking there's a
new system that's being built it's an
alternative it doesn't necessarily have
to be a replacement but that system has
very different structural components to
it if you have 100% confidence that the
current system is going to persist
forever you should keep a hundred
percent of your assets in that dollar
denominated ecosystem but if you even
think that there is one percent
possibility that this other system has a
chance of being successful
you should quote-unquote get off zero
and you should move some of your dollar
denominated assets into that new
alternative financial system and so that
is where
we get into you know sizing the the risk
correctly etc most people we see doing
this are doing it and kind of hundred
basis point type
you know allocations to begin with but
obviously being able to get them off
zero now they've got some skin in the
game they're paying attention and we
tend to find that they you kind of go
down the rabbit hole once they're off
zero at kinetic crypto wants to know how
do you think we can get merchants to
start accepting Bitcoin and crypto more
regularly yeah this great question so I
think that there's two components to
this one there there's an education
piece of it people just got to be more
educated on what is Bitcoin why should
they accept it how is it beneficial and
also kind of a one a component of this
is having customers called going it's a
head do you accept Bitcoin I'd like to
pay you a Bitcoin that tends to move
merchants pretty easily the second thing
is also an economic argument so
something as simple as there's a lot of
businesses now that will actually give
you a discount on the purchase of goods
if you use Bitcoin because they don't
have to worry about the chargebacks and
the credit card fees and and all the
kind of legacy issues that merchants
have and so I think that you know
explaining that to folks around here is
why this could be beneficial to you in
your business I think is an economic
argument and then also an education you
know kind of component to it and there's
a lot of people who are working hard to
do this there's a lot of companies that
have built technology to kind of help
facilitate this so I think we're on our
way but but it takes time and and the
more people we have out there the better
at Canadian huddle what if first world
governments choose to ban Bitcoin to
retain financial control similar to the
gold ban is this plausible look
anything's possible
it's definitely a world where I think
more and more people are paying
attention in kind of the government
ranks the good news is that I think
every government that this I've seen
talked about it there are some
proponents of
of Bitcoin and kind of what the industry
stands for again that doesn't
necessarily mean that they couldn't ban
ownership I think the important thing is
they couldn't shut it down right so they
couldn't shut down the network what they
could do is they could ban ownership and
basically say you know turn over your
Bitcoin all that kind of stuff it's it's
plausible but I don't think that we're
near that happening anytime soon and so
you know I think it's Matt Odell who's
one of these guys who who puts it well
he goes look prepare for the worst and
kind of plan accordingly but also
understand that you know we're still
very early in the stages of this and you
see the central bank's trying to wrap
their heads around you know what is this
stuff should we be participating in it
and so I don't think that's something to
worry about kind of in the short term
Alex crypto onine what will happen after
the last Bitcoin is mind if incentive
for miners this transaction fees would
this be sufficient yeah I think that's a
general belief right now is that the
transaction fees for miners would end up
being the incentive with all the
information we have now I do think that
it would be enough to keep those miners
on again it's hard to kind of predict
what happens 120 years out in the future
but but I think structurally that that's
that's directionally correct and so as
you know we get more information I'm
sure people will kind of reevaluate and
and morph their opinions but but I think
that's a generally held belief right now
at Chaka 321 what's the most important
movie you have ever seen the most
important movie I've ever seen
it's a really good question I don't know
if I've got a the most important movie
but there's that there's a watch of
movies that I really like for those they
don't know I'm a big big movie buff
polina's laughing right now because
whenever I get on a an airline I can
immediately tell whether the movie
library is as good or not because I fly
way too much
but I would say good movies that they
just kind of jump to mind a huge line
King fan which is something that I think
is probably not expected I really really
like the greatest showmen which is
actually a musical but I like that story
and kind of the family components to it
etc I like Cinderella man I think that's
a good one for brothers is another one
and then I am notorious for probably
having watched every war movie known to
mankind but but all of those I think are
up there and then one other one that I
think people probably wouldn't expect
and I I'm gonna get the name incorrect
so I probably should figure it out and
put it in like the show notes is the
life of MIT I think it's called but it's
basically the story of a guy who's stuck
he's a photographer at a magazine and he
stuck in his job and he's just locked
into corporate America can't escape and
he somehow gets thrown on this wild
journey where he realizes like you only
get one life to live and go have
adventure and enjoy it and basically you
could imagine that the movie pretty much
is like him you know thrown the middle
finger up to his corporate job and say
like I'm gonna go live my life but but I
think that that's a pretty powerful
movie for those that feel like they're
locked into into the little monkey cage
and the cubicle tell them how you make
me watch movie trailers and I hate it
so I'm regretting already happening
plane to come help me with this but
there's a joke that we saw online which
perfectly emulated this which was if you
ever want to go watch a movie and you
don't know what you want to watch well
the best way to figure out what the
movie to watch is is to watch all the
movie trailers well if you watch four or
five six ten twelve different movie
trailers in a row then now you're not
watching a movie you're just sitting
there watching movie trailers and so and
so I enjoyed doing that because it's you
know kind of try before you buy
but what you end up seeing is it's movie
topless it's basically the ability to
watch as much as you can and kind of try
a bunch of different things all at the
same table
so this is from Jake at Jason benek
which US Bank do you believe will be the
first to break tradition and embrace
Bitcoin deposits transfers in
transactions it's a great question I
think the first one to buy a crypto
company that has done that I don't think
any of the major banks are going to kind
of jump in the water headfirst and just
do it themselves I think what ends up
happening is they're gonna do it via
acquisition they're gonna see a crypto
native business that's super profitable
and growing really fast and and when
they see that they're gonna realize the
economic benefit to them and they'll go
and they'll just buy it rather than
build it incorporate it internally and
then kind of scale it out using their
resources in their scale at the state of
[ __ ] one on two hundred podcasts ranked
the top ten interviews you have had or
the ones you believed were most impacted
man okay short answer I can't do that
but maybe I what I can do is I can throw
out a couple that were really fun for me
Mourad and I I don't think I'll ever top
the episode we've recorded he he came in
and it was the right time it was the
perfect message he articulated it's so
kind of eloquently that uh it just you
know it got a lot of attention for all
the right reasons and so I think that's
probably the number one episode I
remember recording other ones that stick
out in my mind I remember the one I did
with Catelyn long she was one of the
first three that I did I really really
liked when I kind of got to sit down and
pick her brain and really understand how
she saw the world
that woman was good the what I'll call
the celebrity Club Kyle Bass Anthony
Sierra Moochie and and Spencer Dinwiddie
those three guys all for various reasons
were were kind of memorable just that
their world is not Bitcoin but but they
all had various levels of interest in it
for different things and then I would
also say that some of the conversations
I've had
that weren't so Bitcoin native also are
quite interesting and and so anytime
that I can talk to somebody who's really
smart and has a lot of has kind of a lot
of ideas and can articulate them well I
love to sit down with them and talk want
to know who has the best URL crypto calm
that's right
crypto calm there crypto platform with
one goal mother mass adoption that's why
we're all here we're trying to get
crypto in every wallet crypto calm is
helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto calm
go help your boy out
tell them pomp sense you download the
app or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha
everybody got some electricity and Wi-Fi
all you got to do is go to coin mine
comm you buy a coin mine it's like an
Xbox or a Playstation that helps you
turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just your update your
coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right
go to coin mine calm tell them pomp
Sencha and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor blocked
by their new interest account allows you
to securely deposit your Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive six
percent annual interest paid monthly and
cryptocurrency
this rate actually compound so you
receive a 6.2 percent APY which is very
attractive given the alternatives so you
can actually take your Bitcoin you can
deposit it with block Phi and get paid
an interest rate of 6% in return go
check out block 5 comm slash pump again
block 5 comm slash pump to sign up and
start earning interest on your crypto
today
um @yj Fang 22 you guys got to get
better Twitter names what are the three
biggest developments that we should pay
attention to in the crypto space over
the next one to two years three biggest
developments I think there's going to be
an acceleration of every stock bond
currency and commodity getting digitized
I think that there's going to be even
greater levels of humans trusting
algorithms and software over other
humans I think that we're gonna see
large financial banks start to
incentivize their users to use stable
coins or digital dollars so whether
higher levels of interest better rewards
on a credit card that type of stuff then
the fourth thing is I think that bitcoin
is going to start to take even more of a
material share of global transactions
like I think that bitcoin is a really
quiet beast when you look at the hash
rate and the transactions and all the
things that are happening there I think
people are drastically under estimating
what it can do and so paying attention
that's gonna be important as well okay
Abhinav a car wall 94 give us three
reasons why the government should adopt
Bitcoin slash cryptocurrency yeah
there's a good question I don't know if
I've got three reasons kind of quick
clearly articulated but the things that
kind of jump the top of my head are one
anytime you're doing bilateral trade
between nations as the president of the
United States has been highlighting
there's tons of manipulations of
currencies and economies something like
bitcoin is a non-sovereign backed
currency meaning that if you're two
countries you know that the other
counter party to the transaction is not
manipulating their currency they can
trust that you're not manipulating yours
because you guys are using something
that is outside of the control of both
of you and it's fully transparent and
you can in verifiable so I think that's
kind of one - is the Fiat experiment and
that probably doesn't work over a really
long period of time and so I think
that's going to end up being something
that's important to pay attention to and
so just like individuals should have
kind of that chaos hedge or schmuck
insurance
that governments doing that as well it
makes a lot of sense another third thing
and one of the things that I think goes
on talked about a lot is the ability to
turn excess power into capital right and
one of those most scarce resources in
the world all these countries have lots
and lots of excess power a lot of us
renewable power and what they're trying
to figure out is what do they do with it
and so there's not much thing there's
not many things that are better than
simply let's go blow up mining
facilities let's set those up and let's
start securing this computing network
that is already the most powerful
computer in the world and most secure
computer in the world and so I think
that that's a third reason and an
economic argument as to what they should
be doing with it at irritated wasp in
your opinion what gives billionaires
reason to be pessimistic about BTC what
would or could produce optimism for them
and does this matter what got them here
is not what we're talking about if
you're a billionaire and especially if
you're you know quote-unquote self-made
or you didn't inherit the money the
dollar-denominated inflationary
fractional reserve system worked pretty
damn well for you you you kind of won
the game if you will and so the idea
that people are saying we should switch
the rules of the game or we should go
play a different game probably aren't
super attractive to you because it's an
exact contrast to what built the system
you know built the wealth you have and
so I think that it's no surprise it's
just them talking their book frankly so
I think that's one piece what brings
them into it is there's actually a lot
of I think billionaires are wealthy
folks who realize just because what got
me here doesn't mean it's gonna get me
there right and so there's the world's
changing and when the world changes I
need to reevaluate from a first
principle standpoint what the future
looks like and so those folks are are
hard at work trying to understand that
at Clint Eastwood 1 what are the most
important three books you have ever read
and what's on your reading list
currently yeah so the three most
important books Rich Dad Poor Dad
thinking Grow Rich and the richest man
in Babylon and and really I think of the
most important book is always what the
book was who you were at the time and
and the timing of when you read the book
so those three all read together like I
previously said in terms of books that
I've read recently I really liked Sam's
Elle's book I read a Steve Schwarzman
new book let's see what else I've ever
read I read edward snowden's a permanent
record I'm currently reading a book
called the telomere effect which is all
about kind of our DNA and how it relates
to aging basically the DNA strand at the
end of your DNA has something that is
over generalized in a simple or
simplistic way similar to like the
plastic caps on the end of your
shoelaces
know that that kind of closed off the
DNA strand and as you have a more
stressful life you sleep less you eat
worse you don't exercise etc those
plastic caps or those telomeres end up
shortening and as they shorten you age
faster and so if you've ever seen
somebody who's you know 25 years old but
they look 40 that's probably because
they have short telomeres and so this
book basically goes into the science
behind it and some of the things that
you can do to kind of stop the
shortening of the telomeres or even
reverse it and help to elongate them at
Chuck's neat work so whatever what are
these means alright if if a robot takes
your job is it entitled to support you
for the rest of your life no I think you
know if you've ever seen the the saying
or Lamar Jackson of the Baltimore Ravens
at the after these NFL games even
wearing a shirt that says nobody cares
work harder and so I don't think that
it's in income the automated world that
nobody cares I think actually a lot of
people are talking about this so a lot
of people care but but the idea of
working harder that works in sports
I don't think working harder is going to
solve the problem here I think what
people need to do is they need be very
intelligent of
out optimizing for skills that computers
and machines aren't going to be able to
do and so you know one of these ideas
that I have is that creativity is
mispriced meaning that you know the
machines are going to be really good at
doing monotonous kind of repetitive work
with the ideas of creativity of kind of
the human ingenuity etc that's gonna be
really hard to replicate with machines
and computers and so if you can figure
out how to start to get into a world
where that's your advantage I think
you'll be in a good position and then in
terms of should the Machine actually
support you [ __ ] no I think that the the
idea is you know most people are
monetizing their physical labor or their
intellectual labor right and that's how
they're getting paid but one of the
things that we all do is we create a lot
of data
I've talked that you know pretty
extensively about the idea that all of
that data eventually you're gonna own
you'll hold it in a wallet and as people
want to buy it from you they basically
you can permission them in or out so
something as simple as how many steps
you took today what your heart rate is
what your blood pressure is what you ate
kind of your insulin levels you know all
that kind of data that that's something
like an Apple watch and a couple of very
easy tests could configure out there's
gonna be a lot of health care companies
that want to buy for either research or
marketing purposes or whatever and so
they'll Biden anonymous in a kind of
aggregated format and you'll have to
permission them in to do that
and in exchange for you giving up your
data to be included in the data set then
you'll get paid something and so I think
that we can get to a world where kind of
the basic needs of the human are met by
simply allowing them to monetize that
data it's not gonna happen overnight
it's gonna take some while to get there
but but I definitely think that that's
gonna be a much kind of more
capitalistic approach to solving the
problem rather than kind of you know
kind of more socialist hey you the
machine or the government should take
care of you
at being sim 84 how many people in
percentage of Bitcoin buyers actually
pay something with it and don't use it
for speculation
it's a great question I don't think we
know the answer which is also part of
the advantage of Bitcoin is we don't
know what people are using it for so
when we look at like on chain
transaction volume it's really hard to
tell what people are doing with it and
so I think that that's you know one part
of the strength of Bitcoin - it makes it
really hard to answer this question
obviously it is not as many people as we
would you know think it is but but at
the same time one of the things I
started to talk a lot about with
institutional investors is you know the
last questions like well you can't buy
coffee with it where people don't buy
coffee with them and what I expected
them is you probably don't buy coffee
with dollars right what you're likely
doing is when you go into that coffee
shop you're swiping using credit and
then you're paying off the credit card
at the end of the month and so that when
that happens yes you're using a dollar
denominated system but you're actually
using dollars using credit and so I
think that bitcoin is very similar here
and that people are using other aspects
of it or they're using it for other
things than buying coffee but over time
as the second third fourth layers get
built on top of it will get more
scalability it'll be much easier from a
consumer experience user interface
etcetera and so that kind of more p2p
transactions or merchant based
transactions will will accelerate but
but again we're 11 years into this thing
and so I think we've just got to be
patient and understand at times on the
side of Bitcoin Illinois bloxy one
how will crypto change political
fundraising I don't think it'll change
really that much I definitely think that
kind of the ethos if there's a campaign
or a candidate that really buys into
kind of what bitcoin is and how it works
probably the most the closest candidate
today is something like an Andrew yang
around all the automation and
and you know Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies and blockchain etc but
I don't think that whether a candidate
accepts US dollars or or Bitcoin it's
really going to matter it really just
comes down to our people willing to
donate to support somebody's ideas and
thankfully in the United States we've
got a democratic process or as close to
it and and and those campaigns have to
kind of work to get the support of
people and so I don't think that a
Bitcoin will end up changing it it's all
I got for you that's it all right guys
thanks so much I appreciate it
go go fall Polina on the internet she
she loves when everyone from the crypto
world tweets at her
I'm joking because she has a in the
notifications of her Twitter is a
incredibly peaceful and calm and kind
and everyone is so loving towards each
other and then she will see all of us in
the crypto community and she's like oh
my god I can't believe that you guys
talk to each other that way yeah be
nicer so thanks so much for listening
Pluto thanks for helping me do this and
we'll see you guys next time bye hey
everyone pop here if you like this
episode of off the chain and want to
help us take crypto to the top of the
Apple Spotify and other podcast charts
please do us a favor and rate review and
subscribe to review simply go to the
off-the-chain homepage scroll down until
you see the five blank stars taking 15
seconds to fill those stars in and leave
a quick review goes a long way in
helping us take the entire crypto
ecosystem to the top of the charts I
appreciate you listening and see you
next time on off the chain
[Music]